hi i'm sabina stanley a planetary
scientist at johns hopkins university
i'd like to share with you one
implication from the famous apollo moon
rocks
that is not so widely appreciated it's
an exciting story
a story in which the giant planets
change their distance from the sun
the story begins like this four billion
years ago
the inner solar system apparently
experienced an
unexpectedly large number of meteor
collisions
that scientists typically call the late
heavy bombardment
this was over 500 million years after
the sun and planets had formed
so the number of collisions should have
been declining
not suddenly increasing the evidence for
a spike in the number of collisions came
first and above all from the apollo
missions
bringing back lunar samples for study on
earth
many of these famous samples from the
moon were of rocks that had been
deformed or created by
melting during large impacts these
crystalline melt rocks
could not have formed without large
impacts tens to hundreds of kilometers
in extent
and here's what was surprising the ages
of those melt rocks
all cluster between about 3.75 and 3.95
billion years ago
this suggested that several large
impacts occurred on the moon
during a concentrated time period of 200
million years
geologically a short amount of time
other lunar samples provided ages for
some of the large
impact basins we see on the near side
like the imbrium
nectaris and serenitis basins
the ages of the large impact basins were
somewhat more spread out
from about 4.2 billion to about 3.7
billion years old
so there's some uncertainty about how to
describe the duration of bombardment
but the evidence seems strong that there
were a lot more
impacts and much larger impacts around
this time
compared to earlier or later times
some supporting evidence also comes from
craters on mercury and mars
plus meteorites that have landed on
earth but based primarily on moon rocks
the evidence points to a spike in the
number of impacts
around four billion years ago okay
so what could cause a sudden spike in
the number of impactors
traveling to the inner solar system and
hitting our moon in other locations
we would normally expect a steady
decline in the number of impactors over
time
if there was a big increase in the
number of impacts
then perhaps there was also a big but
more
temporary disturbance something big that
perturbed a much larger number of
impactors inwards from the asteroid belt
and kuiper belt
if we want a big disturbance the biggest
planets especially jupiter are the
natural place to look
computer simulations allow us to study
how the giant planets formed
and gravitationally interacted early in
the solar system
these simulations demonstrate that the
giant planets can migrate their orbits
somewhat
during their formation this idea that
giant planets like jupiter and satellite
actually migrate was a huge surprise
but the idea makes more sense after
studying thousands of exoplanets
orbiting other stars
sometimes those gas giant planets
migrate
very close to their parent stars in our
own solar system
we don't really know what the original
configuration of the giant's planets was
just after they formed but we can run
lots of simulations with different
possibilities
and see which ones eventually evolve
into the system we see today
one model that does a very nice job is
the so-called nice model
nice here refers to the city of nice
france because the model was initially
developed by
scientists at an astronomical
observatory near nice
so the nice model begins with the four
giant planets
jupiter saturn uranus and neptune
situated more closely in space
than they are today their orbits were
more compact
fitting all four planets between about 5
and 17
times earth's distance from the sun
compare that to today
where jupiter resides at five but saturn
is at nine
uranus at 19 and neptune is all the way
out at
30 times earth's distance from the sun
during this early time a disk of icy
planetesimals where the total mass of
tens of earth masses would have existed
out beyond where the giant planets were
forming
out there the orbital speeds were too
slow and the material too sparse to form
a giant planet
every once in a while an icy
planetesimal from this disk
would be perturbed into the region of
the giant planets
but when one of these planetesimals is
scattered inwards by a planet
the giant planet's orbit is pushed a bit
outwards momentum must be conserved
it's similar to why pushing yourself off
a skateboard in one direction
means the skateboard goes in the other
direction
so now picture one of these
planetesimals first encountering neptune
on its way in
pushing neptune outward a tiny bit as
the planetesimal moves inwards
then the planetesimal gets to uranus and
scattered inwards
even more moving uranus out a tiny bit
and the same thing happens yet again
when the planetesimal encounters saturn
now admittedly these outward
perturbations of the giant planets would
be extremely small
and not every encounter would result in
an inward scattering of the planetesimal
other directions are still possible but
on average
the odds are better that the
planetesimal gets scattered inwards
when encountering neptune uranus and
saturn
and if successive planetesimals are
getting scattered inward over and over
again
then the combined effect can be to move
the planet's orbits outwards
but something different happens when the
inward scattered planetesimal finally
reaches jupiter
jupiter is so massive that jupiter is
more likely
on average to fling the planetesimal
into a highly elliptical orbit
taking the object further outward in the
solar system but every time a
planetesimal is flung
outwards then jupiter migrates inwards a
bit
so jupiter moves inwards while saturn
uranus and neptune each move outwards
and all this continues to go on for some
time
until jupiter and saturn end up in a
very special configuration
as jupiter is moving inwards its orbital
period is decreasing
as saturn's orbit is moving outwards its
orbital period is increasing
eventually they reach a state where
jupiter completes exactly
two whole orbits every time saturn
completes one
they are now in a two to one orbit orbit
resonance
what this resonance means is that
jupiter and saturn can gravitationally
influence each other more
and in a quite regular way and what
happens
is they also perturb each other into
orbits that are less circular and more
elliptical
that means that jupiter and saturn cross
through a larger range of orbital
distances
during their orbits but taking the two
biggest planets in the solar system
and giving them orbits that are less
circular and causing them to visit
new places can cause all hell to break
loose among all the remaining
planetesimals in the solar system
saturn quickly moves to a new position
closer to where we find it today
out around 10 astronomical units 10
times earth's distance from the sun
but if saturn moves then this has
implications for uranus and neptune
gravitational interactions with saturn
move uranus and neptune
onto more elliptical orbits of their own
pushing them
to cross farther out in the solar system
but as uranus and neptune migrated to
orbits farther from the sun
that destabilized the disk of small
bodies out near pluto
some of those icy planetesimals from
what is called the kuiper belt
would be thrown into the inner solar
system producing a spike in bombardment
of the inner planets and about half the
time when you run simulations with the
nice model
neptune and uranus switch places during
their outward migration
in these versions of the model neptune
was originally closer to the sun than
uranus
the reverse of what we have today this
scenario is appealing because neptune is
almost 18
more massive than uranus for a given
composition
we would have expected all other things
being equal for neptune
the more massive to form closer to the
sun where the protoplanetary disk was
denser
anyway the end scenario is the giant
planets
where we see them today preceded by
movement of the giant planets
that caused increased bombardment in the
early solar system
a lot depends on small details in the
initial conditions of the models
but many possibilities lead to a major
destabilization migration
of the giant planets and flinging of
planetesimals
into the inner solar system and there's
even more
but this gives you an idea i love how
the nice model
opens our eyes to possibilities the
orbits of the giant planets
dance around the solar system as the
giants migrate
and the model is able to explain some
previously taken for granted features we
see in the solar system
but we don't know for sure that the
model describes what actually happened
even the late heavy bombardment one of
the major consequences that made the
nice model so attractive
may not be real that's because
there is some debate over evidence from
the moon rocks supporting the claim that
there was a spike in large impacts
around 4 billion years ago
the debate stems from looking at the
locations where we got our lunar samples
during the apollo missions after all it
was these lunar samples
that provided the first and strongest
evidence that a late heavy series of
large impacts occurred
in a relatively short geologic time
but it's possible that all of these moon
rock samples are
actually sampling from just one very
large impact crater on the moon
imbrium that's not because we collected
all the samples from a single location
but because the imbrium impact would
have spread ejecta
over large distances surrounding the
basin and since imbrium is the youngest
of the large impact basins
the ejecta would have landed on top
could it be possible
that samples we collected from six
different locations on the moon
all happened to be ejected from imbrium
if so
that would explain but a very different
way
while the ages in the samples cluster
around the age of imbrium
all those impacts still happened it's
just that they may not have happened so
close together in time
instead it may be that there was a more
steady and less dramatic flux of
impactors from the beginning of the
solar system
4.5 billion years ago down to about 3.5
billion years ago
without a spike centered at 4 billion
years ago
and the fact that we don't see a lot of
impact milk crystals older than about
4.2 billion years
maybe simply because older material was
more likely to be pulverized by later
impacts
perhaps virtually all the older evidence
has been destroyed
so which is it was there a concentrated
bombardment caused by a dance of the
giant planets
or not perhaps the most important thing
that will help are more samples from the
moon
from a wider variety of locations and
different impact basins
after all the ages of surface features
on mars
mercury and venus are all anchored to
ages of craters determined from lunar
samples
combined with counting and comparing the
relative number of craters on each world
if more samples from the moon resulted
in a correction to the ages previously
determined for lunar features
that would cause to revise the timing
and sequence of events throughout the
inner solar system
the timing of events early in the solar
system may be
fundamentally changed by better
knowledge of lunar impact basins
bringing samples back from the moon now
seems so easy
we did it during the apollo program and
yet no samples have been brought back to
earth from the moon
since the mid-1970s naturally
scientists have lots of hopes and plans
for new samples from the moon
the more samples the better a picture we
can develop about the timing of lunar
impacts and the solar system as a whole
we need to return to the moon to sample
from other locations on the moon
that have no chance of containing the
ejecta from the relatively young
imbrium basin we need a bigger
collection of moon rocks to tell us when
and whether a concentrated period of
late heavy bombardment
even happened at all and once we confirm
or revise when and whether a big
increase in impacts occurred
that will confirm whether the giant
planets really did go
dancing around the solar system
disrupting all the smaller bodies and
causing a time
with a huge increase in impact craters
in short
more moon rocks are going to tell us how
the solar system formed
[Music]
you